When he was 15, Lee was living illegally in the United States. He'd come over from China, and he worked in a series of Chinese restaurants in small towns in Pennsylvania, Ohio, New York. He didn't speak English, though he wanted to. He didn't go to school, though he wanted to. Instead, he and the other illegal immigrants working in these restaurants lived in tiny apartments, sometimes in the back of the restaurants, sleeping on bunk beds, working 12 hours a day, six days a week.
李15岁时，以非法身份住在美国。他从中国来到这里，在宾夕法尼亚州、俄亥俄州和纽约州等小城镇的一系列中餐馆打工。虽然他想学，但不会说英语。虽然他想去，但没法上学。相反，他和餐馆里的其他非法移民住在狭窄的公寓里，有时就住在餐馆后面，睡着双层床，每天工作12小时，一周工作6天。
The one thing that I can tell you is that we had really little contact with other people, you know what I mean?
我能告诉你的一点是，我们和其他人的接触真的很少，你明白我的意思吗？
The thing that must have been so strange, though, is that you're working in a restaurant, and so you would see all these people come in, and you would see families with kids and people your own age. And it must've just seemed like they were on the other side of some sort of wall that you could never climb over.
不过，最奇怪的事情肯定是，你在餐馆工作，会看到所有人走进来，会看到带着孩子的家庭，看到和你年纪相仿的人。他们看起来就像生活在某种你永远无法逾越的高墙的另一边。
Yeah. I feel like it's a different world. It's like people don't even see you sometimes, if you're working behind a restaurant. Sometimes you feel mad, you feel angry, that you can't be like them. And then you try to think about why. I can't find a reason.
是的。我觉得那是一个不同的世界。有时候，如果你在餐馆后厨工作，人们甚至都看不见你。有时你会感到疯狂，感到愤怒，因为你不能像他们一样。然后你会试着去想原因。我找不到原因。
We talked about this a while. And finally, I told Lee that it seemed like he was living in a kind of limbo-- not his old life in China, not a real American life. And he agreed.
我们聊了一会儿。最后，我告诉李，他似乎生活在一种中间状态（limbo）中——既不是他在中国时的旧生活，也不是真正意义上的美国生活。他表示同意。
Limbo, yeah. Right between, somewhere in between, and you don't know where it is, actually.
中间状态，没错。就在两者之间，某个位置，实际上你根本不知道那在哪里。
You know, the idea of limbo comes from the church. And originally it was used to describe people who aren't going to heaven, but they aren't bad enough for hell.
你知道，limbo这个概念来自教会。最初它是用来描述那些上不了天堂，但又没坏到要下地狱的人。
Yeah, I know what this means. Yeah.
是的，我知道这是什么意思。是的。
Which country is the heaven and which country is the hell?
那哪个国家是天堂，哪个国家是地狱呢？
Well, I don't know if you've heard-- there's a TV show in China. It's called Peking People in New York.
嗯，我不知道你有没有听说过——中国有个电视剧，叫《北京人在纽约》。
Peking People in New York?
《北京人在纽约》？
Yeah. You know the city of Peking, right?
是的。你知道北京这个城市吧？
Sure. Beijing.
当然，Beijing。
Beijing. OK. So it's the title of the TV show. And every time the TV show comes out, every time an episode comes out, there's a code. So if you like the person, send the person to New York, because it is heaven. If you hate a person, also send the person to New York, because it is hell. Every time you see that episode, you see this code. [UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE] I thought it was fun.
北京。好的。这就是那部电视剧的名字。每次电视剧播出时，每一集出来，都有一个代码。如果你喜欢那个人，就把他送到纽约，因为那是天堂。如果你讨厌那个人，也把他送到纽约，因为那是地狱。每次看到那一集，你都会看到这个代码。[听不清的短语] 我觉得这很有趣。
Yes, America can be heaven. It can be hell. But today on our program, American Limbo, stories of people who somehow have ended up living completely outside the grid of normal American life. We have three stories for you in three acts.
是的，美国可能是天堂，也可能是地狱。但今天我们的节目《美国式的中间地带》（American Limbo），讲述的是那些不知何故最终完全游离于正常美国生活轨道之外的人的故事。我们为您准备了三个篇章，三个故事。
Act One, The Family That Flees Together, Trees Together. I know that does not make a lot of sense right now, but believe me, it will. It will.
第一幕，《逃亡的家庭，扎根的家庭》。我知道这听起来没什么道理，但相信我，会有道理的。会的。
Act Two, What's French For "Steeee-rike Three?" An American parent abroad tries to make his kid more American using the powerful force that is American baseball, and how is it that any kid could resist that?
第二幕，《法语里“好球三振”怎么说？》。一位身在海外的美国父亲试图用美国棒球这种强大的力量让他的孩子更像美国人，有什么孩子能抗拒这种力量呢？
Act Three, It's Julie Andrews' World, Sylvia Just Lives in It, in which one girl takes a tape recorder to college and documents her first year in just 11 minutes.
第三幕，《这是朱莉·安德鲁斯的世界，西尔维娅只是生活在其中》，讲述一个女孩带着录音机去上大学，并在11分钟内记录了她的大一生活。
From WBEZ Chicago and Public Radio International, it's This American Life . I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
来自芝加哥WBEZ和国际公共广播电台，这里是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act One. This is the story of a family that drops out entirely from society, goes on the run after they get in trouble with the law. Two parents, six kids, no money, making do as they can for seven years. And how do the kids turn out after all that? Actually, surprisingly, kind of great. The family is called the Jarvises. This American Life producer Alex Blumberg visited them in Florida.
第一幕。这是一个完全脱离社会的家庭的故事，他们在惹上法律麻烦后开始逃亡。一对父母，六个孩子，没有钱，七年来勉强维持生活。所有这些之后，孩子们变成了什么样？事实上，令人惊讶的是，他们过得还不错。这个家庭叫贾维斯（Jarvis）一家。《美国生活》制片人亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）在佛罗里达探访了他们。
Here's a typical scene in the life of the Jarvis family. The kids are gathered around a shallow well, maybe three feet deep. An alligator is trapped inside. Their first instinct? Rescue the poor thing.
这是贾维斯一家生活中的一个典型场景。孩子们围着一口浅井，大约三英尺深。里面困着一只短吻鳄。他们的第一本能是什么？救救这个可怜的小家伙。
Poor thing, eh?
可怜的小家伙，呵？
[? James, ?] just reach your hand down there and pull it out.
[？詹姆斯，？] 直接把手伸进去把它拉出来。
No, I don't want to do that.
不，我不想那么做。
Well, he just keeps whipping so fast.
好吧，它一直在剧烈挣扎。
Stick your hand in his mouth and see what he does.
把手伸进它嘴里看看它会怎么样。
That's Anna, 14, the youngest girl, advising her brother Cy, 21, to stick his hand in the alligator's mouth. Cy has a different idea, a completely ingenious one, and in a moment, he's holding a kind of makeshift noose in his hand.
那是14岁的安娜（Anna），家里最小的女孩，建议她21岁的哥哥赛（Cy）把手伸进短吻鳄的嘴里。赛有不同的主意，一个非常巧妙的主意，片刻之后，他手里拿着一个临时做的套索。
I'm going to take this snare that I got and I'm going to put it over his mouth and then I'm going to pull it tight so he can't bite.
我要用这个我做的圈套，把它套在它的嘴上，然后拉紧，这样它就咬不到了。
And where'd you get that snare?
你从哪弄的这个套索？
I just made it real quick, whipped it out of some string and some sticks. Come on, there, gator, just relax. Just relax.
我很快就做好了，用绳子和棍子缠出来的。来吧，鳄鱼，放松点。放松点。
For seven years, the Jarvis family lived on the run-- in a treehouse in a cypress swamp, in the rotting hull of a boat, anywhere they could hide. But before that, for over 20 years, they lived in a house they built themselves, far from anyone, in the middle of a forest in West Virginia. They grew most of their own food in their garden. A natural gas well on their property powered their appliances. They had no electric bill, no heating bill. This is the mom, Eileen Jarvis.
七年来，贾维斯一家一直在逃亡——在柏树沼泽的树屋里，在腐烂的船壳里，任何他们能藏身的地方。但在那之前，他们在一座自己盖的房子里住了20多年，远离人群，身处西弗吉尼亚州的森林深处。他们大部分的食物都来自自己的花园。房产里的一口天然气井为他们的电器供电。他们没有电费单，没有暖气费单。这是妈妈，艾琳·贾维斯（Eileen Jarvis）。
We just wanted to make our own little world, really, and have our handle on it. I feel like my kids grew up in Never-Never Land.
我们只是想创造我们自己的小世界，真正拥有掌控权。我觉得我的孩子们是在“永无乡”（Never-Never Land）长大的。
Did they really? How so?
真的吗？怎么说？
They had 140 acres plus to run around and play in and they used every bit of it. They had a treehouse or a fort in every tree.
他们有140多英亩的地方可以跑来跑去玩耍，他们利用了每一寸土地。每棵树上他们都有树屋或堡垒。
Eileen and her husband Ron were '60s back-to-the-land dropouts who'd actually stayed dropped out. Their home in the 1990s looked a lot like it did in the 1970s-- vegetarian dinners, barefoot children, lots of wood carvings. Even the crops they grew were the same, which in 1992 became a problem when a helicopter spotted a marijuana patch Ron was growing on the property.
艾琳和她的丈夫罗恩（Ron）是60年代“回归自然”运动的脱离者，而且真的坚持了下来。他们在90年代的家看起来和70年代没什么两样——素食晚餐，赤脚的孩子们，大量的木雕。甚至连他们种植的庄稼也一样，这在1992年成了问题，当时一架直升机发现了罗恩在房产上种植的一块大麻地。
My son Asa was going to cut the grass and he had the lawn mower on, and I had dinner cooking. And Asa came running in the house and he said, "Dad said to get in the van." So we just left-- left the stove on, the pressure cooker on. Dinner in the-- coffee, I had just made a pot of coffee and poured it up. And we took nothing with us. The kids didn't have shoes on their feet. We just walked out of the house and that was it.
我儿子阿萨（Asa）正要去割草，割草机开着，我正在做晚饭。阿萨跑进屋说：“爸爸说去面包车里。”于是我们就离开了——留下了炉子，压力锅还在那。晚餐在——咖啡，我刚煮了一壶咖啡倒出来。我们什么也没带。孩子们脚上连鞋都没有。我们就那样走出了房子，一切就这样结束了。
If you ask Ron Jarvis about the marijuana patch today, he says he planted it earlier in the year, right after his wife was diagnosed with cervical cancer, to sell and pay for her treatments. He also says he smoked pot regularly his whole life, and some of his kids did too.
如果你今天问罗恩·贾维斯关于大麻地的事，他说他是在年初，也就是他妻子被诊断出宫颈癌后不久种下的，为了卖掉钱来支付她的治疗费用。他还说他一辈子都有规律地抽大麻，他的一些孩子也抽。
I still don't see myself as a criminal. But my decision to grow that pot caused my family to have to suffer that trauma. And it's one of the things that I feel really responsible for. It wasn't a good decision.
我至今不认为自己是个罪犯。但我种植大麻的决定导致我的家人不得不遭受那场创伤。这是我感到非常内疚的事情之一。那不是个好决定。
The Jarvises hit the road, and it was hard. They couldn't stay with anyone they knew without implicating them into their crime. They couldn't drive their van. They couldn't rent an apartment or get a job without showing ID, and they couldn't show ID without popping up in a background check. They had six kids, the youngest seven years old, and they had seven dollars in their pocket. In retrospect, Eileen says she and Ron were just trying to do the right thing.
贾维斯一家踏上了流亡之路，过程非常艰难。他们不能和任何认识的人住在一起，以免牵连对方犯罪。他们不能开自己的面包车。他们不能在不提供身份证明的情况下租房或找工作，而他们又不能提供身份证明，否则背景调查就会弹出。他们有六个孩子，最小的才七岁，口袋里只有七美元。回想起来，艾琳说她和罗恩当时只是想做正确的事。
I knew I was going to be arrested, and I knew they weren't going to let me take my kids to jail with me. No, I just knew it wasn't going to be good. It wasn't going to be good. All of a sudden, I think all my kids are going to be scattered out into foster homes. Everything's flowing through my head. No, they weren't going to-- it just wasn't going to be good.
我知道我会被捕，我知道他们不会让我带着孩子去坐牢。不，我只知道这不会有好结果。这不会有好结果的。突然之间，我想到我所有的孩子都会被分散到寄养家庭。脑子里乱成一团。不，他们不会——这绝对不会有好结果。
The Jarvises caught some lucky breaks. A family friend who happened to be passing through that day, and happened to be driving a van, took them to Maryland, where all eight of them crashed in a friend's one-room attic. And for two months, it went like this. Ron and his friend would get up before dawn, drive to the forest and collect wood. By sun-up, they were back at the house, out in the backyard, cutting and bending it into benches, tables, and chairs. The kids all helped, sanding, finishing, weaving seat bottoms. If it rained, they put plastic tarps over their heads. Once they got a big enough furniture pile, they'd go to boat shows around Annapolis and sell it by the side of the road.
贾维斯一家遇到了一些好运。一位正好那天路过的家庭朋友，恰好开着一辆面包车，把他们带到了马里兰州，八个人都挤进了一个朋友的一居室阁楼里。接下来的两个月，日子是这样过的：罗恩和他的朋友每天黎明前起床，开车去森林收集木头。日出时分，他们回到房子，在后院里将木头切割并弯曲成长凳、桌子和椅子。孩子们都来帮忙，打磨、上漆、编织座垫。如果下雨，他们就在头上盖塑料布。一旦家具堆得足够多，他们就会去安纳波利斯周围的船展上，在路边卖掉它们。
I would have a reoccurring dream, and I know that some of my kids would, too, of just walking through that house and looking at everything. But you're not there to stay. You're just walking through the house. And I would just see it all. The play room where the kids played, all their toys they'd had through all the years. The lofts that they slept in. I could just see everything. And the one thing that I would always be focusing on in my dreams would be grabbing that Swiss Army knife while I'm going through the kitchen really slow, and grabbing that Swiss Army knife so I had it with me.
我常做一个反复出现的梦，我知道我的一些孩子也做过，梦见在那个房子里走来走去，看着每一件东西。但你不是留在那里，你只是走过房子。我能看到所有东西。孩子们玩耍的游戏室，他们多年来拥有的所有玩具。他们睡觉的阁楼。我能看清一切。我梦里总是会聚焦的一件事就是，在缓慢穿过厨房时抓住那把瑞士军刀，抓住它，这样我就能随身带着它。
Are you serious?
你是认真的吗？
I'm serious. I'm very serious.
我是认真的。非常认真。
I didn't really realize that we were going to have to leave there forever.
我当时真的没意识到我们要永远离开那里。
This is the oldest girl, 19-year-old Molly Jarvis.
这是家里的大女儿，19岁的莫莉·贾维斯（Molly Jarvis）。
I kind of figured we were going to be able to go back in a few days. That's what I figured. I was thinking, where are we going to stay for a few days until we go back?
我当时觉得我们过几天就能回去。我是这么想的。我在想，在回去之前我们要在哪待几天呢？
The boat that would eventually be their home was at that point at a dock in the Annapolis Yacht Club. The club was planning to saw it up, sell it for scrap, but when Ron asked about it, they said they'd sell it to him instead for $5,000. It was full of holes, half rotted out. Exchanging a cramped attic for a dilapidated boat that barely floats might not seem to be such a great trade, but the day the Jarvises finally moved in was one of the happiest in a long time. They patched the holes with tar and plywood, stowed all their stuff in the hull, and had a friend tow them to what would become home for the next two years, down the bay to a marina called Backyard Boats. Manager Ginger Griffith.
那艘最终成为他们家的船，当时停在安纳波利斯游艇俱乐部的一个码头上。俱乐部打算把它锯开当作废铁卖掉，但当罗恩打听时，他们说可以以5000美元卖给他。那艘船满是窟窿，半个船体都烂了。用狭窄的阁楼换一艘几乎浮不起来的破烂船看起来并不是什么好买卖，但贾维斯一家最终搬进去的那天，是他们很久以来最幸福的一天。他们用柏油和胶合板补上了漏洞，把所有家当塞进船舱，找朋友把船拖到了他们接下来两年要住的地方，那是海湾下游一个叫“后院船只”（Backyard Boats）的码头。经理是金格·格里菲斯（Ginger Griffith）。
Right there, what looks like a big slip from here? That's where they pulled in when they first came here. One of the guys in the yard came in the office and said, "Ginger, there's a boat here wants to be hauled, but I think you'd better look at it." I said, "OK," so I came out and I really walked down to just about where we are now. So, what, 50 feet from the dock? And I just took one look at that and said, in my heart, "What a sight that is." It was leaking. They had pumps going on it, probably four or five pumps running full-time to keep it floating. The family looked tired. And I thought, a mother of all those children on that boat. Thank god it's not me.
就在那儿，从这儿看像个大船坞的地方？他们刚来的时候就是停在那儿的。院子里的一位员工走进办公室说：“金格，这儿有条船想拖上来，但我建议你最好先看看。”我说：“好吧”，我就走出来，走到离这儿差不多现在这个位置。什么，离码头50英尺？我一眼看过去，心里就说：“天哪。”它在漏水。他们有泵在工作，可能有四五个泵在全天候运行才能让它浮着。那家人看起来很累。我想，一个带着这么多孩子的母亲住在那种船上。谢天谢地，那不是我。
It just touched me, right away, seeing them. I can't see how it wouldn't touch anybody if they could have seen them that way. You could tell that this was not a family at its best.
看到他们那一刻，真的触动了我。如果有人能像那样看到他们，我不相信这不会触动任何人。你能看出这家人并不处于最好状态。
The Jarvises were not the typical Backyard Boats customer. For one thing, most customers didn't bring their boat in for repairs with their entire eight-person family aboard. For another thing, most customers went home after the boat was hauled out of the water and placed on jacks in the repair lot. They didn't do what the Jarvises did, which was climb aboard the boat, suspended on its jacks, and proceed to live on it while they repaired it.
贾维斯一家不是“后院船只”的典型客户。首先，大多数客户不会带着全家八口人住在维修的船上。其次，大多数客户在船拖出水面并放在修理场的支架上后就回家了。他们不会像贾维斯一家那样，爬上悬空在支架上的船，然后在修理它的同时住在里面。
It was cramped in there. The three girls slept in a room the size of two refrigerator boxes, too low to stand in, even if you're a 12-year-old girl. The planking was all in the process of being replaced, so there were holes in the hull which they covered with plastic tarps. They bathed in a shower they rigged up under the boat behind makeshift plywood walls. And for two years, they lived without the slightest bit of privacy from each other. They couldn't make a move without everyone else in the family knowing about it. But none of this bothered them. 19-year-old Molly and her 17-year-old sister Lily explain what did.
里面很挤。三个女孩睡在两个冰箱纸箱那么大的房间里，甚至连12岁女孩都站不直。木板都在更换过程中，所以船体上有洞，他们用塑料布遮盖。他们在船后临时搭建的胶合板墙后用自己改装的淋浴器洗澡。在那两年里，他们之间没有任何隐私。他们一举一动，全家人都知道。但这并没有困扰他们。19岁的莫莉和她17岁的妹妹莉莉（Lily）解释了什么才是困扰。
There was people. There was lots of people, which wasn't a normal thing in West Virginia. Because we used to be back in the woods, and all of a sudden, we were right in the middle of town. Everything was different about it. Everything.
这里有人。有很多很多人，这在西弗吉尼亚可不是常态。因为我们以前住在树林里，突然之间，我们就到了市中心。这里的一切都不同了。所有的一切。
You'd see different people every day. That was not normal. We had regular friends, and it was the first time we could walk down the street to your friend's house. It was like we had company every day.
你每天都会看到不同的人。这很不正常。我们有了固定的朋友，这是我们第一次能顺着街道走到朋友家。就像每天都有客人一样。
What was it like going over to your-- did their parents ever ask you, what do your parents do, and that sort of thing?
去朋友家是什么感觉？他们的父母有没有问过你，你父母做什么之类的问题？
People ask you, you know, "Why did your parents sell their farm in West Virginia just to live on that ratty old boat?" "Oh, I don't know. They just like boats."
人们会问你，“为什么你父母要卖掉西弗吉尼亚的农场住在那条破烂的旧船上？”“哦，我不知道。他们就是喜欢船。”
And what did you say?
那你怎么说？
I don't know. You just kind of talk your way out of it. just be vague.
我不知道。你只能设法应付过去，模棱两可。
That was hard. But that just can't be casual conversation. I was just always afraid of getting someone else in trouble.
那很难。那根本不能算随意聊天。我总是害怕给别人惹麻烦。
To the best of my knowledge, no one knew anything about any details of their past.
据我所知，没有人知道他们过去的任何细节。
Again, Backyard Boats manager Ginger Griffith.
还是“后院船只”的经理金格·格里菲斯。
In fact, let's see. After it was a long time, it became very normal, we just didn't think anything other than the fact that maybe they were sort of like hippies and enjoyed living in their boat under the primitive conditions, that that's what they chose to do. We even forgot about the fact that there may have been a story behind this, and just kind of accepted that that's the way they wanted to live. And if people were to ask, we'd say, "Oh, they're fine. They just like to live like that."
事实上，让我想想。过了很久之后，这就变得非常正常了，我们只是觉得他们可能就像嬉皮士一样，喜欢在这种原始条件下住在自己的船上，这是他们自己的选择。我们甚至忘记了这背后可能有什么故事，只是接受了他们想那样生活。如果有人问，我们会说：“哦，他们挺好的。他们只是喜欢那样住。”
Over time, the Jarvises played a larger and larger role in the community. Eileen got a job helping Ginger manage the office at the marina. The oldest boy, Yancy, started working as a rigger. And his brothers Asa and Cy were hotly sought after to race other people's boats. The girls were still home-schooled, but they babysat and got jobs detailing boats, running the fuel dock. The Jarvises had taken the classic fugitive trajectory and reversed it. They hadn't fled civilization for isolation. They'd been flushed out of isolation and they could only get away by blending back into civilization.
随着时间的推移，贾维斯一家在社区里扮演的角色越来越重要。艾琳在码头找了份工作，帮金格管理办公室。大儿子扬西（Yancy）开始做索具工。他的哥哥阿萨和赛成了别人争相聘请的帆船赛手。女孩们仍然在家上学，但她们做保姆，还找了份清理船只、管理燃油码头的工作。贾维斯一家完成了经典的逃亡轨迹并进行了反转。他们没有为了孤立而逃离文明，他们是被从孤立中“冲”出来的，只有通过重新融入文明才能获得自由。
What was it like becoming friends with more typical American kids?
和更多典型的美国孩子交朋友是什么感觉？
It was OK. It really wasn't that different. I didn't think it was that hard.
挺好的。真的没那么不同。我觉得没那么难。
It wasn't different at all? They go home to their house, they watch their TV, and you go home to a boat and roll out your bed? That wasn't different? You didn't feel like it was different?
一点也不不同？他们回到房子，看电视，你回到船上，铺开床？那不不同吗？你不觉得这很不一样吗？
It was just what we did, so I just thought that was normal, I guess.
这就是我们做的事情，所以我猜那是正常的。
Some kids live in houses and some kids live on boats. Some kids live in treehouses.
有的孩子住在房子里，有的孩子住在船上。有的孩子住在树屋里。
The other thing that's amazing to me is that you were doing this at the age when-- like, when I was 12 or 13, that was the worst-- that was when I was most susceptible to peer pressure, and when I felt most like an outcast. And when I felt like I was different than everybody and it was a horrible feeling. And here you were, actually different than everybody, but you didn't feel that way?
另一件让我感到惊讶的是，你们是在那个年纪做这些事——比如，我12或13岁的时候，那是最糟糕的时候——那是我最容易受同伴压力影响的时候，也是我最觉得自己是个局外人的时候。我觉得我和别人不同，那是一种糟糕的感觉。而你们，实际上和每个人都不同，但你们却不那么觉得？
No, none of the kids were mean to us or anything. Nobody was ever mean to us, never. No, we didn't feel weird. We knew we were different, I guess. But we didn't feel like we were inferior to anybody.
不，没有孩子对我们刻薄。从来没有人对我们刻薄，从来没有。不，我们不觉得自己很奇怪。我想我们知道自己不同，但我们不觉得低人一等。
I should mention here another fact about the Jarvises. They're all, from the oldest boy to the youngest girl, beautiful. The girls have silky long blonde hair. The boys are tanned, high-cheekboned, and muscley. If there were a movie version of their story, it might be the only film in history where the Hollywood actors are actually less good-looking than the people they're portraying.
我得提一下关于贾维斯一家的另一个事实。他们从大儿子到最小的女儿，都很漂亮。女孩们有丝绸般的长金发。男孩们晒成了古铜色，颧骨高耸，肌肉发达。如果要把他们的故事拍成电影，那可能是历史上唯一一部好莱坞演员其实比他们所饰演的人物还要不好看的电影。
Combine this with the fact that they're all incredibly talented, they're unfailingly polite, good-natured and thoughtful, they seem to have no familiarity with adolescent angst, and that for years they emerged this way each morning, radiant and glowing, from within the hull of a half-built boat on jacks in a gravel repair lot, you can see why people are impressed. Here's Ginger Griffith.
再加上他们都极具天赋，总是彬彬有礼，性格随和且体贴，似乎没有任何青春期的苦恼，而且多年来他们每天早晨都这样从砾石修理场支架上那艘半成品的船壳里走出来，光彩照人，你可以看出为什么人们会对他们印象深刻。这是金格·格里菲斯。
They just were an inspiration. I mean you'd just think, what an ideal family. Wouldn't it be neat to have a family that involved with each other and concerned? I mean, the little girls were making baskets and painting pictures, and it was all so good. And the mother would take time to acknowledge what they were doing and to advise them or praise them or whatever. And all in such a positive way that the girls would just skip out of here inspired to do even more. It was wonderful.
他们简直是一种激励。我的意思是，你会想，多么理想的家庭啊。如果有一个家庭成员之间如此亲密和关心，那该多好。我是说，小女孩们在编篮子、画画，一切都那么美好。而母亲会花时间去认可她们在做什么，给她们建议或赞美等等。一切都以如此积极的方式进行，女孩们跳着跑出去，受到激励做得更好。这太美妙了。
After two years at Backyard Boats, the sharp spike of adrenaline that every Jarvis felt at the sight of a flashing blue light had softened into a dull jab. The boat was beautiful, all hand-carved wood, and two months away from being seaworthy. And the Jarvises themselves were two months away from disappearing onto the sea. And then they got a call from Ron's sister. The FBI had threatened to put her in jail. She'd had to tell. They were on their way. Once again, the Jarvises grabbed what they could and left.
在“后院船只”待了两年后，每个贾维斯人在看到闪烁的蓝光时感受到的那种剧烈的肾上腺素尖峰，已经变成了一种沉闷的刺痛。那艘船很漂亮，全是手工雕刻的木头，再过两个月就能下海了。贾维斯一家离消失在大海上也只剩两个月了。然后他们接到了罗恩姐姐的电话。联邦调查局威胁要送她进监狱。她不得不说了。他们正在赶来的路上。贾维斯一家再次抓起能带走的东西，离开了。
I just figured we were always going to live like this.
我只是以为我们永远会这样生活。
Again, the oldest daughter, Molly.
还是大女儿，莫莉。
I thought we were always going to almost get caught, just like we always did, and then always get away. That's what I figured. I didn't think they were ever going to get caught. I didn't think that was ever going to happen.
我以为我们总是会差点被抓住，就像我们以前总是那样，然后总是能逃掉。我是这么想的。我没觉得他们会被抓住。我没觉得那种事会发生。
We haven't been here since probably '97.
我们可能自97年以来就没来过这里了。
What are we looking at here?
我们在这儿看什么？
We're looking at our treehouse, our other home sweet home.
我们看我们的树屋，我们另一个温馨的家。
I'm standing in the middle of a cypress swamp on the Suwannee River in western Florida with five of the eight Jarvises. They've brought me here to show me one of the last places they lived during their life on the run.
我和八个贾维斯人中的五个正站在佛罗里达州西部苏万尼河（Suwannee River）的一个柏树沼泽中央。他们带我来这儿是为了给我看他们逃亡期间住过的最后几个地方之一。
Are the floors rotten, Molly?
地板烂了吗，莫莉？
The treehouse is about 10 feet off the ground, suspended in the Vs of two large oak trees. Ron built it out of swamp cypress himself, using only a hand saw. It took him one month. We go up a staircase built of unfinished cypress branches lashed together. Inside, it rivals anything you've seen on Gilligan's Island .
树屋离地约10英尺，悬挂在两棵大橡树的V字杈上。罗恩用沼泽柏树亲自建造的，只用了一把手锯。花了他一个月。我们走上由未加工的柏树枝绑在一起的楼梯。里面可以媲美你在《吉利根岛》（Gilligan's Island）里看到的任何东西。
This is the living room. We had a chair here and we had a settee here and another chair in here somewhere. This held all our fruits and veggies, this hollow log. And over here, Ron had built a fireplace.
这是客厅。我们这里有个椅子，那边有个长椅，这里某个地方还有另一把椅子。这个中空的木头用来放我们所有的水果和蔬菜。在那边，罗恩盖了个壁炉。
We found this picnic table top floating down the river too.
我们在河里漂流时也捡到了这个野餐桌板。
Floating down the river. And this was a find, a table top, so we brought that up here and Ron made this bar for us so we could eat around it.
在河里漂来的。这是个宝贝，一个桌面，我们就把它搬上来，罗恩为我们做了这个吧台，这样我们就可以围着它吃东西。
The Jarvises only lived in the treehouse for two months before a nosy game warden forced them to move on again. From there, they went back and forth around Florida. They were living on their boat in a marina in Saint Augustine when marshals finally caught them. Eileen says that they'd felt for months that they should move on, but that life had gotten comfortable, the boys with their own boats, everybody working a good job, the family all together. When agents finally did show up, it wasn't a surprise, really. Eileen went to jail for three months, Ron for a little over two years.
贾维斯一家只在树屋里住了两个月，就被一个爱管闲事的野生动物管理员赶走了。从那儿以后，他们在佛罗里达州来回奔波。当法警最终抓住他们时，他们正住在圣奥古斯丁（Saint Augustine）一个码头的船上。艾琳说他们几个月来一直觉得该离开了，但生活变得舒适了，男孩子们有了自己的船，每个人都有不错的工作，全家人在一起。当联邦特工最终出现时，其实并不让人意外。艾琳坐了三个月牢，罗恩坐了两年多。
It's surprisingly beautiful in the swamp. The river is wide and there's herons flying and nesting all along it. The girls swim and splash in the water. Eileen tells me that their years on the run have affected each of her children differently. And once it gets dark, while she and the girls go and prepare dinner, I talk to her youngest boy, Cy, who's 21, and whose outlook differs quite a bit from his sisters and mothers about what he's learned since the family first fled West Virginia.
沼泽里出奇地美。河面宽阔，苍鹭在上面飞翔和筑巢。女孩子们在水里游泳嬉戏。艾琳告诉我，多年的逃亡生活对她每个孩子的影响各不相同。天黑后，当她和女孩们去准备晚餐时，我和她最小的儿子赛谈了谈，他21岁，对自从家里逃出西弗吉尼亚州以来所学到的东西，他的看法与他的姐妹和母亲大不相同。
We really didn't know how people were. And people are basically beasts. Because most people aren't very friendly. Of course, we were lucky there. At Shady Side, a lot of them people were basically friendly people. They were primitive thinkers, but they were real friendly and they were nice people, and most of them were just out to help instead of out to get you, they were out to help you. And during winter time, we didn't have no money, and we didn't basically have no walls around us because they were all so rotten. And people were all the time coming by and offering us heaters and blankets and all kinds of stuff. So it was nice of them. All the people around there were great. And like I say, they were basically primitive thinkers, but they were really nice people.
我们真的不知道人们是什么样。人类基本上就是野兽。因为大多数人并不怎么友好。当然，我们那次很幸运。在Shady Side，那些人中大部分基本上是友好的人。他们是原始思维者，但他们确实很友好，是好人，他们大多数人不仅不是为了算计你，而是为了帮助你。冬天的时候，我们没有钱，而且因为墙壁太烂，我们基本上没有什么遮挡。人们一直过来给我们提供取暖器、毯子和各种东西。他们真是太好了。周围的所有人都很棒。就像我说的，他们基本上是原始思维者，但他们真的是好人。
What do you mean by that?
你这是什么意思？
Primitive thinkers? What I mean by that is they don't mind. They don't mind eating meat and smoking cigarettes, and they don't mind running over that animal that crosses the road. And they don't mind just shooting something, and they don't mind killing something. And they don't mind driving their diesel boats all over the place and spilling motor oil in the water. And the words they say, they're pretty much foul. And the stuff they discuss don't need to be discussed around kids and family, and don't need to be discussed, period. That's what I mean by primitive thinkers. Just not really understanding what right is and what wrong is. They don't know the difference between the two.
原始思维者？我的意思是他们不在乎。他们不在乎吃肉和抽烟，也不在乎碾过马路上横穿的动物。他们不在乎直接射杀某些东西，也不在乎杀死某些东西。他们不在乎到处开着柴油船，把机油洒在水里。他们说的话相当恶心。他们讨论的东西不需要在孩子和家人面前讨论，而且根本就不应该讨论。这就是我说的原始思维者。就是不太明白什么是对的，什么是错的。他们分不清两者的区别。
Primitive thinker-- is that your term or is that your dad's term? Or is that something that--
原始思维者——这是你的术语还是你爸爸的术语？或者这是……
That's my term. That's what I've learned.
这是我的术语。这是我学到的。
The rest of your family doesn't seem to feel this way exactly.
你的家人似乎并不完全这么觉得。
They don't seem to feel this way because-- I don't know, they watch a little bit more TV than me and they listen to more radio. And I'm not attacking them when I say it, but yeah, they're primitive thinkers. And it's not like I made this stuff up. I just deal on a level of right and wrong.
他们似乎不这么觉得是因为——我不知道，他们比我看更多的电视，听更多的广播。我这么说并不是在攻击他们，但没错，他们是原始思维者。这也不是我编出来的。我只是用对错的标准来处理事情。
How did you come by your notion of right and wrong?
你是怎么产生对错观念的？
I didn't come by it. It's right and it's wrong. There's not two different rights and there's not two different wrongs.
不是我产生的。对了就是对了，错了就是错了。没有两种不同的对，也没有两种不同的错。
But I mean, how did you figure it out, then? How do you explain the fact that other people don't know it and you do?
但我的意思是，那你怎么搞清楚的？你怎么解释别人不知道而你知道这个事实？
Well, what I see as being wrong is what has happened to my dad. That's what I see as being wrong. They can come into your house with guns and point the guns at you and take what's yours and do whatever they want. They can come into your house and they can stomp their cigarette butts out on your carpet. And they can pull all your clothes out and throw it on the floor. And they can go through your cabinets and dump flour on the floor, and your oatmeal and everything on the floor just to make a mess. It's not like you're hiding something in the oatmeal. Why do they need to do that? And they can kick down your doors and break out your windows, and they can walk through your house, and they can put anything they want in their pockets.
嗯，我所看到的是错误的，就是发生在我爸爸身上的事。那就是我所认为的错误。他们可以带着枪进到你家，用枪指着你，拿走属于你的东西，随心所欲。他们可以进到你家，把烟头掐在你的地毯上。他们可以把你所有的衣服拿出来扔在地板上。他们可以翻遍你的橱柜，把面粉撒在地板上，把你燕麦片之类的东西全扔在地上，只是为了制造混乱。就好像你在燕麦片里藏了什么东西一样。他们为什么要那么做？他们可以踹开你的门，砸碎你的窗户，他们可以在你的屋子里走来走去，把任何他们想拿的东西放进兜里。
For what reason? Because he grew some marijuana and smoked marijuana? Did he force anybody else to smoke this marijuana? No. He didn't, did he? Was he shooting anybody over this marijuana? No, he wasn't. He was teaching us kids how to build furniture and how to be real men. And he had time to do all that because he smoked the marijuana and he had time to sit and think about what he had to do. And so what happened to him was wrong. That's what happened to him, the wrong thing. What he was doing was right.
为了什么理由？因为他种了一些大麻并抽大麻？他强迫别人抽这个大麻了吗？没有。他没这么做，对吧？他因为这个大麻射杀任何人了吗？没有，他没有。他正在教我们孩子如何制作家具，如何成为真正的男人。他有时间做这一切，因为他抽大麻，他有时间坐下来思考他必须做的事情。所以发生在他身上的事情是错误的。这就是发生在他身上的事情，错误的事情。他所做的是正确的事情。
Most of the family wouldn't maybe put it the way Cy does. But they all claim some version of the separation he feels from the world at large. Molly and Lily say they feel older than everyone they meet. Eileen says she sometimes feels she's on the outside looking in. The trade-off is what they do have, a fierce, unyielding, unbreakable devotion to each other.
家里大多数人可能不会像赛这样说。但他们都宣称某种程度上认同他与大世界的分离感。莫莉和莉莉说她们觉得自己比遇到的任何人都老。艾琳说她有时觉得自己是个局外人，在往里看。代价是他们所拥有的东西——一种对彼此强烈、不可动摇、坚不可摧的奉献。
All right, so you've got a song for us?
好了，那你给我们准备了一首歌吗？
No, I don't really know any songs. I can only really make noise. [GUITAR MUSIC]
不，我真的不知道任何歌。我真的只会制造噪音。[吉他音乐]
When I visit, the Jarvises are living on the boat they first bought in Maryland, the one they rebuilt themselves, made beautiful. They all gather in the galley most nights to eat. A lot of times, Cy and Yancy will get out their guitars. Asa plays the drums and the family sings. There they are in this self-contained world they've built themselves by hand, together. From the boat, you can see the shoreline of the United States of America.
我探访时，贾维斯一家正住在他们在马里兰州买的第一艘船上，就是他们自己重建的那艘，他们把它变美了。他们大多数晚上都会聚在餐厨区吃饭。很多时候，赛和扬西会拿出他们的吉他。阿萨打鼓，全家人一起唱歌。他们就在这个由他们亲手打造的世界里，在一起。从船上，你可以看到美国的大地。
Alex Blumberg. Coming up, two people try to nudge themselves out of limbo and closer to everyday American life. Guess just how many of them succeed. Just guess. In a minute, from Public Radio International, when our program continues.
亚历克斯·布伦伯格。接下来，两个人试图让自己走出中间状态，更加接近日常的美国生活。猜猜他们有多少人成功了。试着猜猜。一分钟后，来自国际公共广播电台，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose some theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program, American Limbo, stories of people who have accidentally ended up outside the grid of normal American life. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, What's French for "Steeee-rike Three?" This is the story of an American in Paris who chose to live in Paris, but decided at some point that he wanted to nudge his kid toward a little more American-ness. But when one does this kind of thing, it's on instinct and it's a guess, and you cannot tell how it'll come out. Here is that dad to tell the story, Adam Gopnik.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周的节目都会选择一个主题，带给您关于该主题的各种不同故事。今天的节目，《美国式的中间地带》，讲述那些偶然最终游离于正常美国生活之外的人的故事。我们现在进行到节目的第二幕。第二幕，《法语里“好球三振”怎么说？》。这是一个美国人在巴黎的故事，他选择住在巴黎，但在某个时刻决定想要把他的孩子往美国文化的方向推一推。但当一个人做这种事时，凭的是直觉，是一个猜测，你无法预知结果会如何。这里是那位父亲亚当·戈普尼克（Adam Gopnik）讲述这个故事。
I don't really remember how we first thought of the rookie. I think it may have been right after I saw my son, Luke, who had just turned three, playing with a soccer ball in the Luxembourg Gardens. It wasn't just the kicking that scared me, but the kind of nonchalant, bend-of-the-body European thing he did as he rose to meet the ball with his head. Next he would be wearing those terrible shorts and bouncing the ball from foot to foot, improving his skills. He had been born in New York, but he had no memory of it. Paris is the only home he knows.
我不记得我们是怎么第一次想到那个“新人”（the rookie）的。我想那可能是在我看到我刚满三岁的儿子卢克（Luke）在卢森堡公园踢足球后。让我害怕的不仅仅是踢球动作，还有他起跳头球时那种漫不经心、身体弯曲的欧洲式动作。接下来他肯定会穿着那件糟糕的短裤，用双脚颠球来提高技术。他出生在纽约，但他对此毫无记忆。巴黎是他唯一知道的家。
"You want to have a catch?" I said, and he looked at me blankly.
“想跟我玩接球吗？”我说，他茫然地看着我。
That night at bedtime, I said, "Hey, I'll tell you about the rookie." It was 8 o'clock. The sun was still out, but the sounds had become less purposeful. You could hear small noises, high heels on the pavement, and though this is a pleasant times to lie in bed in Paris, it is not an easy time for a small boy to go to sleep.
那天睡觉前，我说：“嘿，我给你讲讲关于那个新人的故事。”那时8点钟。太阳还在挂着，但声音已经变得不那么有目的性了。你能听到小小的声响，高跟鞋敲击路面的声音，虽然这是在巴黎躺在床上的美好时光，但对一个小男孩来说，这并不是容易入睡的时候。
I had been drawing storytelling duty for awhile, and had made increasingly frantic efforts to find a hit, like a network programmer back home massaging the schedule. A story about a little boy who turned into a golden fish in Venice hadn't gone anywhere, and a remake of The Hobbit had done no box office at all. This story, though, rolled out easy.
我担任讲故事的职责有一阵子了，为了找个爆款，做出了越来越疯狂的努力，就像国内的电视网络制片人在调整时间表一样。一个关于威尼斯小男孩变成金鱼的故事没起什么作用，重拍的《霍比特人》票房也一塌糊涂。不过，这个故事讲起来却非常顺手。
The rookie, I said, was a small boy in Anywhere, USA, in the spring of 1908. Out walking with his mom one day, he discovered that he had an uncanny gift for throwing stones at things. He picked one up and threw it so hard that it knocked a robin off its perch a mile away. And then after his mama chided him, he threw another one, just as far, but so softly that it snuggled into the nest beside the bird without breaking an egg.
那个新人，我说，是1908年春天美国某地的一个小男孩。有一天和他妈妈一起散步时，他发现自己在投掷石子方面有惊人的天赋。他捡起一颗石子，投得如此用力，以至于把一英里外栖木上的一只知更鸟打了下来。然后，在他妈妈斥责他之后，他又投了一颗，同样远，但却柔和地钻进了那只鸟旁边的巢里，连个蛋都没打破。
His parents, a little sadly, but with a sense of obligation, immediately sent him off on the train to New York to try out for the New York Giants and their great manager, John J. McGraw. All he took with him was a suitcase that his mother had packed for him, filled with things, including his bottle, that he thought might be useful in case of an emergency.
他的父母有点难过，但出于义务感，立即让他坐火车去纽约，去参加纽约巨人队及其伟大的经理约翰·J·麦格劳（John J. McGraw）的试训。他只带了一个手提箱，是他妈妈收拾的，装满了各种东西，包括他的奶瓶，他觉得万一有紧急情况可能会有用。
He got out at Grand Central, took a cab all the way uptown to the Polo Grounds-- his mother had told him to take taxis in New York-- and asked to see John J. McGraw. McGraw, staccato and impatient, was at first skeptical, but he finally agreed to watch while the kid threw, because he was so polite and the letter from his parents was so insistent, and because, well, you never know. He called Big Six, the great Christy Mathewson, out of the dugout to watch, and Chief Meyers, the great American Indian catcher, to get behind the plate. The Chief came out, with a weary, crippled, long-suffering gait, and squatted.
他在中央车站下车，坐出租车一路往北到了马球场（Polo Grounds）——他妈妈告诉他在纽约要坐出租车——然后要求见约翰·J·麦格劳。麦格劳语气生硬、不耐烦，起初很怀疑，但最终同意看孩子投球，因为他非常有礼貌，父母的信也很坚持，而且，好吧，谁知道呢。他叫出大名鼎鼎的“大六”克里斯蒂·马修森（Christy Mathewson）走出休息区观看，叫出伟大的美国印第安捕手迈尔斯（Chief Meyers）蹲在本垒后方。迈尔斯迈着疲惫、瘸腿、长期受苦的步伐走出来，蹲下了。
I thought of the Chief as a creased veteran, though the real Chief was still in his 20s, and not yet even a Giant.
我把迈尔斯想象成一个饱经风霜的老将，尽管真正的迈尔斯当时才20多岁，甚至还不是巨人队的队员。
The little guy walked to the mound, tugged at his cap-- not a baseball cap, the cap of his knickers suit-- and let fly. Everybody was impressed, to put it mildly. "Hey, Mr. McGraw," cried the Chief, "I ain't never seen speed like that. And then he got movement on it, too."
小家伙走到投手丘上，拽了拽他的帽子——不是棒球帽，是他灯笼裤套装上的帽子——然后投出了球。平心而论，大家都印象深刻。“嘿，麦格劳先生，”迈尔斯喊道，“我从来没见过那样的速度。而且他还带着位移。”
"Well," Matty said mildly, peering at the tiny, [? dowdy ?] figure on the mound. "When you think about it, he's more or less got to have that upward movement on his fastball, don't he?" My ideas of credible 1908 ballplayer dialogue were heavily influenced by Ring Lardner. McGraw shrugged, since tryouts were one thing and baseball was another. But in the end, he decided to give the kid a start that Sunday in a big benefit exhibition that the Giants were playing at the Polo Grounds against the Detroit Tigers.
“嗯，”马修森轻声说道，盯着投手丘上那个细小、[？破旧的？]身影。“想想看，他的直球差不多必须得有那种上飘，对吧？”我对1908年可靠的棒球运动员对话的构想深受林·拉德纳（Ring Lardner）的影响。麦格劳耸耸肩，因为试训归试训，棒球是另一回事。但最后，他决定让孩子在那个周日参加巨人队在马球场对阵底特律老虎队的一场盛大的慈善表演赛中首发。
I stopped. Outside, we could hear the steady stop-and-start rhythmic passage of the sanitation workers. Impossibly chic, in grass-green uniforms with a white stripe running down the side, the men of the [SPEAKING FRENCH] came down our street every night to collect the garbage.
我停了下来。外面，我们能听到清洁工节奏稳定的走走停停的步伐。穿着草绿色制服，侧面有一条白条，时髦得不可思议，[法语]的人们每天晚上都会来我们街上收集垃圾。
"Go on," Luke ordered, muffled but sharp from under his covers. "Stop thinking."
“继续，”卢克在被子里闷声但尖锐地命令道。“别思考了。”
In the benefit exhibition that Sunday, I went on at last, the big bathtub-shaped stadium with its strange supporting wide beams, was packed with fans come to see the three-year-old phenom. The rookie took the mound, throwing smoke. And fans, it looked as though it might be a first, a perfect-perfect game. 27 men up, 27 K's, until in the sixth, the rookie had to face the terrible Ty Cobb.
在那场周日的慈善表演赛中，我继续说道，那个浴缸形状的体育场及其奇怪的支撑横梁，挤满了来看这位三岁神童的球迷。新人登上投手丘，投出了疾速球。球迷们看来这可能是史上第一次，一场完美的比赛。27个人上场，27个三振，直到第六局，新人不得不面对可怕的泰·柯布（Ty Cobb）。
Now, I realized I had a problem here, since Cobb should have been batting cleanup from the start. I explained that he'd been late suiting up, because he insisted on extorting extra payment from the Tigers management for playing in a charity exhibition, even though everybody else was playing for free. Cobb was just like that, I explained. Terrible.
现在，我意识到我有麻烦了，因为柯布应该从一开始就打第四棒。我解释说他当时换衣服迟到了，因为他坚持要勒索老虎队管理层，要求为慈善表演赛支付额外酬劳，尽管其他人都是免费参加。柯布就是那样的人，我解释道。太糟糕了。
The crowd quieted as the confrontation neared. Cobb came to the plate, sneering and drawling. "Hey, baby," he called out, taunting the rookie. "Looks to me like you're nothing but a baby."
当对抗临近时，人群安静了下来。柯布走上打击区，冷笑并拉长调子。“嘿，宝贝，”他喊道，嘲笑那个新人。“在我看来，你不过是个婴儿。”
Luke's whole body stiffened. If there was a worse insult, he hadn't heard it. Jackie Robinson, in his first year with the Brooklyn Dodgers, had never been called a name so vile.
卢克全身僵硬。如果有什么更恶毒的侮辱，他肯定没听过。杰基·罗宾逊（Jackie Robinson）在布鲁克林道奇队的第一年，也从未被叫过如此卑劣的名字。
Shaken, the rookie lost a bit off his heater. It was still blazing, though, and Cobb just got a piece of it, dribbling it towards first. He took off, and the rookie, who knew his assignments, dutifully scampered over to cover. Cobb came in hard, hard as he could, his spikes sharpened to razor tips, and stamped down on the rookie's three-year-old foot. Safe. Stinking, rotten way to get on base, but safe all the same.
受到震动的新人球速慢了一些。不过仍然飞快，但柯布只是碰到了球，把它滚向了一垒。他起跑，而熟悉自己任务的新人，尽职尽责地跑过去补位。柯布冲过来，尽可能快地冲来，他的钉鞋磨得像剃刀一样锋利，重重地踩在三岁新人的脚上。安全上垒。非常恶心、卑鄙的上垒方式，但确实安全了。
Shaking off a couple of tears, the rookie went back to the mound. "Hey, I reckon you're a crybaby. Hey, everybody, look at the crybaby. Looks to me like you're nothing but a crybaby," came the taunting Georgia drawl from first, and the rookie pitched out of trouble. But the pain lingered, and in the top of the ninth, the Giants having pushed over one run on a hit-and-run executed by the Chief, he made a few mistakes, walked a couple of batters-- hey, he was three-- and left himself with the bases loaded and the Georgia Peach due up again.
甩掉几颗泪珠，新人回到投手丘上。“嘿，我想你是个爱哭鬼。嘿，大家看那个爱哭鬼。在我看来，你不过是个爱哭鬼，”从一垒传来的嘲讽声，乔治亚腔的拖腔。新人解决了麻烦。但痛苦依然存在，在第九局上半，在迈尔斯通过打带跑战术跑回一分后，巨人队领先，但他犯了几个错误，保送了几个击球手——嘿，他才三岁——导致垒包被占满，乔治亚之桃（Georgia Peach，柯布的绰号）又要上场了。
The crowd was going crazy and now the taunting began again, worse than ever. "Hey, baby. Hey, crybaby. Why don't you cry some more, crybaby?"
人群陷入疯狂，现在的嘲讽声比以往更甚。“嘿，宝贝。嘿，爱哭鬼。你怎么不再多哭一会儿呢，爱哭鬼？”
The rookie knew what he had to do. In the dugout, he had taken his old bottle from the suitcase his mother had packed for him when he went off to join the Giants, just in case, and stowed it under his cap. Now he dripped a couple of drops of milk onto the seams of the baseball, the rookie's soon-to-be-notorious bottle-ball. It was before they brought in the rule against foreign substances on the ball, I explained. The rookie was playing fair.
新人知道他该怎么做。在休息区里，他把离家去巨人队那天妈妈收拾的旧奶瓶带上了，万一需要的话，他把那个奶瓶藏在帽子下。现在，他把两滴奶滴在棒球的缝线上，这就是新人很快就要出名的“瓶球”（bottle-ball）。我解释说，那是在他们制定针对球上外国物质的规则之前。新人打得很公平。
"Hey, when are you guys going to go to sleep?" Luke's mother's voice came from the other room.
“嘿，你们这些家伙什么时候才睡？”卢克妈妈的声音从隔壁房间传来。
"Soon," I called back abruptly. The lights of the traffic on the Boulevard Saint-Germain came in through the windows, but I didn't even draw the curtains.
“快了，”我生硬地喊回去。圣日耳曼大道上的交通灯光从窗户照进来，但我甚至没拉窗帘。
The rookie stretched and threw, and the bottle-ball dipped and twisted and dipped and twisted again, curving all the way out to the third base line and then cruising halfway towards first before finally slipping in, softly and cleanly, right across the plate, a strike at the knees. Ty Cobb had time to take a really good cut. He had all day, but the pitch had him so fooled that he didn't just whip, he twisted himself in knots while he whipped, real knots. His whole body pulled around like a wet washrag, hands ending up back of his butt.
新人伸展身体投出球，瓶球扭曲、旋转，又扭曲、旋转，一路划向三垒线，然后横穿半场直奔一垒，最终柔和地、干净利落地滑进本垒，一个膝盖高度的好球。泰·柯布本来有足够的时间挥棒。他有一整天的时间，但这一球把他晃得太厉害了，他不只是挥空，他在挥棒的同时把自己扭成了结，真正的结。他的整个身体像一块湿抹布一样扭转过来，手最后停在屁股后面。
Luke chuckled deeply at that.
卢克深沉地笑了起来。
"Steeee-rike three," cried the umpire, and the bleachers of the Polo Grounds went nuts. The rookie trotted off the field. "Who's the baby now, Mr. Cobb?" he asked with quiet dignity on his way back to the dugout.
“好球——三振，”裁判喊道，马球场的看台发疯了。新人跑下场。“现在谁是婴儿，柯布先生？”他在回休息区的路上带着安静的尊严问道。
My kid sat up-- shot up-- in bed, like a mechanical doll, as if he had a spring hinge right at his waist.
我的孩子像机械玩偶一样，从床上坐起——射起——，仿佛他的腰部有一个弹簧铰链。
Christy Mathewson, I went on, didn't say anything. No, that wasn't his way. But he went over as the rookie came into the dugout, took off the rookie's cap, and mussed up his hair. Outside the crowd wouldn't leave. They just chanted, "Rookie. Rookie."
克里斯蒂·马修森，我继续说道，什么也没说。不，那不是他的作风。但当新人走进休息区时，他走过去，摘掉新人的帽子，揉乱了他的头发。场外人群不肯离去。他们只是高喊着：“新人。新人。”
Now the only sound from Luke's pillow was of short, constant breathing. I had the uncanny knowledge of a kind of silent excitement, the certainty-- I had witnessed it once or twice on opening night at a theater, though I had certainly never created it before myself-- that what we had here was a hit. The terrible Ty Cobb had called him a baby, and he had thrown the bottle-ball, and then who was the baby?
现在，卢克的枕头边只剩下短促、持续的呼吸声。我有一种莫名的、无声的兴奋感，一种我曾在一两次剧院首演之夜见证过，但自己从未创造过的确定性——我们这里成功了。可怕的泰·柯布叫他婴儿，而他投出了瓶球，然后谁是婴儿？
That night, I went on, the rookie was offered a contract with the Giants, and the team got on the overnight sleeper to St. Louis, heading out to steamy Sportsman's Park. The Chief tucked the rookie into his berth, and before he went off to play pinochle with the guys, asked him, roughly, "You OK, rookie?"
那天晚上，我继续说道，新人接到了巨人队的合同，球队坐上了前往圣路易斯的过夜卧铺火车，前往潮湿的运动公园球场（Sportsman's Park）。迈尔斯把新人塞进铺位，在去和伙计们玩纸牌之前，粗鲁地问他：“你没事吧，新人？”
"I'm OK, Chief," the rookie said. And then he listened to the sounds of the train tracks clacking and the whistle blowing and the other ballplayers in the next car, laughing and playing cards, before he fell deep asleep somewhere outside Columbus.
“我没事，迈尔斯，”新人说。然后他听着火车轨道卡嗒卡嗒的声音，汽笛声，以及隔壁车厢里其他球员玩牌大笑的声音，在哥伦布郊外的某处沉沉入睡。
"I'm OK, Chief," Luke repeated. And then he did something he had never done before, or at least not in my presence. Without negotiation or hesitation, without tears or arguments or requests to come and sleep in the big bed, he rolled right over and fell asleep.
“我没事，迈尔斯，”卢克重复道。然后他做了一件他以前从未做过的事情，至少在我面前没有过。没有谈判或犹豫，没有泪水或争辩，没有要求去大床上睡觉，他翻了个身就睡着了。
From then on, we had a story about the rookie every night. After a couple of months, I began to wonder, what picture did he summon up when, night after night, he heard the words "Polo Grounds," "full count," "all the way to the backstop?" Not an inexact picture. No picture at all. He had never been to a baseball game, never seen a bat or a glove, never been inside a ballpark or even watched a ballgame on television. No one Luke knew played baseball. No one talked about it. The words and situations were pure language, pure abstract lore.
从那以后，我们每晚都会讲一个关于新人的故事。几个月后，我开始想，当他每晚听到“马球场”、“满球数”、“一直回到后挡板”这些词时，他脑子里会浮现出什么画面？不是不精确的画面。什么画面也没有。他从未去过棒球比赛，没见过球棒或手套，没进过球场，甚至没在电视上看过球赛。卢克认识的人里没人玩棒球。没人谈论过它。这些词和情境纯粹是语言，纯粹抽象的传说。
The cliches I rolled out-- "he had all day," "steamy Sportsman's Park," "no foreign substances on the old pill"-- what did he think, what did he see, when he heard them? I knew that he wanted to hear the words as much as I needed to say them. He zipped through dessert to get to bed every night, but what did the words mean to him?
我抛出的陈词滥调——“他有一整天的时间”、“潮湿的运动公园”、“老球上没有外来物质”——当他听到这些时，他怎么想，他看到了什么？我知道他想听这些词，就像我需要说它们一样。他每晚快速吃完甜点去睡觉，但这些词对他意味着什么？
I had spent my adult life believing that storytelling depends on the credibility of its details. Now, finally, I had made up a story that someone liked, and the details had no credibility at all, no existence except as sounds. You are supposed to use a word, I had always been taught, to point at a thing, and hope that the thing will somehow end up pointing at something bigger-- a feeling, a state of mind. But now I said "Polo Grounds" or "full count" and the words called up in my son a powerful reaction. But what of that second range, where the words were supposed to become things, even just images in his head?
我大半辈子都相信故事讲述依赖于细节的可信度。现在，最终，我编了一个别人喜欢的故事，而细节毫无可信度，除了作为声音，没有任何存在感。我一直被教导，你要使用一个词来指向一个事物，并希望这个事物最终能以某种方式指向更大的东西——一种感觉，一种精神状态。但现在我说“马球场”或“满球数”，这些词在我儿子身上唤起了强烈的反应。但那第二个范围呢，那些词本应变成事物的范围，哪怕只是他脑子里的图像？
There is, I think, a force in stories, words in motion, that either drives them forward past things directly into feelings, or doesn't. And the trouble is, you don't know which way they're going until you've already taken your swing. Sometimes the words fly right over the fence and all the way out to the feelings. Make them do it one time out of three in private, and you've got a reputation as someone who can play a little, a dad who can tell a decent bedtime story. Do it three times out of five in public, and you're Mark McGwire or Dickens.
我认为，故事里有一种力量，一种运动中的词汇，它们要么直接驱动它们越过事物进入感觉，要么就没做到。问题是，在你挥棒之前，你不知道它们会往哪个方向走。有时候，这些词直接飞越栅栏，一直飞到感觉里。在私下里做到三次里有一次，你就有了某种名声，像个能玩两下的人，一个能讲像样睡前故事的爸爸。在公开场合做到五次里三次，那你就是马克·麦奎尔（Mark McGwire）或狄更斯。
After about a year of telling the rookie story, I went to New York to give a talk and I turned the trip into a literary mission, a sort of rookie-collecting expedition. I wanted to bring home tangible evidence of something that, as a matter of fact, had never taken place there. I bought a baseball encyclopedia and a box of books on the Cobb era, and borrowed a Ken Burns video on baseball. A vintage Giants cap, child-size, which I thought would be the hardest thing to find, turned out to be absurdly easy. The past is so neatly packaged now that I just walked into a memorabilia store on Lexington Avenue and found a replica cap, no problem.
在讲了大约一年新人故事后，我去纽约做演讲，我把这次旅行变成了一次文学使命，一种类似“收集新人”的远征。我想带回家一些实际证据，证明一件事实上从未在那里发生过的事情。我买了一本棒球百科全书和一箱关于柯布时代的书，并借了一部肯·伯恩斯（Ken Burns）的棒球纪录片。一顶儿童大小的复古巨人队帽子，我原以为这是最难找到的东西，结果却出奇地简单。现在过去的一切都打包得太整齐了，我走进列克星敦大道的一家纪念品店，买到了复刻帽，一点问题没有。
When I got home to Paris, I put on the video from the PBS baseball series, which I had never seen. And we watched all those flickering, over-frantic little ghost figures racing around. There was Ty Cobb, looking appropriately evil. There was John J. McGraw. There were pitching and batting-- I realized from Luke's comments that he had them the wrong way around. There was base-running. There was Christy Mathewson, and then a picture of Matty, handsome and as short as ever, slowly dissolving into a picture of a small, serious boy with blond bangs, wearing a baseball cap and a perfectly sober expression, going into a pitching windup.
回到巴黎后，我放了那部我从未看过的PBS棒球纪录片。我们看着所有那些闪烁、过度狂躁的小鬼影四处奔跑。那是泰·柯布，看起来确实很邪恶。那是约翰·J·麦格劳。有投球和打击——我从卢克的评论中意识到他把顺序搞反了。有跑垒。有克里斯蒂·马修森，然后是一张马修森的图片，他英俊且一如既往地矮小，慢慢溶解成一张小小的、严肃的、留着金色刘海的男孩的照片，戴着棒球帽，表情非常严肃，正进入投球风车动作。
I still have no idea who he actually was. It's not Christy Mathewson's kid. I found a picture of him and he had darker hair. But of course Luke knew who it was perfectly well. "There he is," he said. "Rewind it." We watched Matty and the rookie appear again, and then he told me to turn it off.
我仍然不知道他到底是谁。那不是克里斯蒂·马修森的孩子。我找到了他的照片，他头发更深色。但当然，卢克非常清楚那是谁。“就是他，”他说。“倒回去。”我们看着马修森和新人再次出现，然后他叫我关掉。
He was uncharacteristically silent for the rest of the afternoon, but before dinner I heard him talking to his mother in the bath. "He had his hands up like this," he was saying chattily. "I don't know why."
那天下午剩下的时间里，他反常地沉默，但在晚饭前，我听到他在洗澡时和妈妈谈话。“他手像这样举着，”他兴致勃勃地说。“我不知道为什么。”
That was enough excitement, enough reality, for one day, I thought. And it wasn't until a week later that I tried out on him a picture of the Chief, an honest-to-god picture of Chief Meyers, looking just as he ought to look. "Hey, look. That's the Chief," I announced proudly, opening the old baseball encyclopedia at his bedside.
那一天的兴奋和真实感已经够多了，我想。直到一周后，我才尝试给他看一张迈尔斯的照片，一张真正意义上的迈尔斯照片，看起来就像他应该有的样子。“嘿，看。那是迈尔斯，”我自豪地宣布，在他床头打开那本旧棒球百科全书。
He paused, looked at the picture, looked back at me, peering in for a moment. And then he got a funny guilty smile on his face that I had never seen there before. "Oh," he said, peering intently at the picture. "I thought it was his mother."
他顿了顿，看了看图片，又看了看我，盯着看了片刻。然后他脸上出现了一种奇怪的、内疚的笑容，这是我以前从未见过的。“哦，”他说，盯着那张照片。“我以为那是他的母亲。”
"What do you mean?" I said, surprised.
“你这是什么意思？”我惊讶地说。
"I mean I knew it was, but I thought it was. I mean, I knew it was a man, but I thought he was the mother," he concluded, stumbling a little. "I thought it was his mother."
“我是说我知道那是他，但我以为那是她。我是说，我知道那是个男人，但我以为他是母亲，”他总结道，有点结巴。“我以为那是他母亲。”
He actually blushed, and I could sense that there was something at once so deep and so important going on in what he was trying to tell me that he feared at some other level it would seem silly. In his mind's ear, he could hear Ty Cobb calling, "Baby."
他竟然脸红了，我能感觉到他试图告诉我的事情既深刻又重要，以至于他在另一个层面上担心这看起来会很愚蠢。在他心灵的耳朵里，他能听到泰·柯布喊着：“婴儿。”
"But remember?" I said. "His mother packed the suitcase for him. He had the mama's suitcase."
“但还记得吗？”我说。“他的母亲为他收拾了手提箱。他有妈妈的手提箱。”
"I know. I know that," he said quietly, stubbornly. "I can't-- I just thought--" He held his hand up to his head and he tried to smile. "I-- I thought it was a girl. I thought it was his mama."
“我知道。我知道，”他安静地、固执地说。“我不能——我只是以为——”他把手举到头上，试图微笑。“我——我以为那是个女孩。我以为那是他妈妈。”
I got it then. He knew that the word, the Chief, stood for some kind of older man, but whether he could have summoned up this kind of older man, a bearded, grizzled 40-ish American Indian catcher with boozy breath, I'm not sure. But the symbolic place that he occupied was so deeply maternal that it was-- well, he was his mother.
我当时明白了。他知道，“迈尔斯”这个词代表某种老男人，但至于他是否能召唤出这种老男人——一个蓄着胡须、满脸风霜、40多岁、酒气熏天的美国印第安捕手——我不确定。但他所占据的象征性位置是如此深刻地带有母性，以至于——嗯，他就是他的母亲。
What had been lulling him sleep, night after night, I realized, was not the all-purpose fit. These words pointed directly to the symbol, and it was the obvious one, but it wasn't my symbol. The trouble with mental catch is that the ball you throw changes in midair into another. Staring down into the Polo Grounds, what he had seen was what he needed to see, and that was the same face he saw at every window. His mama had been there at his bedside all along, and I had been too slow a reader of my own fiction to spot her lurking.
我意识到，每晚让他入睡的，不是那场全能的棒球比赛。这些词直接指向了那个象征，而且是显而易见的那个，但那不是我的象征。精神接球的问题在于，你投出的球在半空中会变成另一个。盯着马球场，他所看到的是他需要看到的，那就是他在每一扇窗户里看到的同一张脸。他的妈妈一直都在他床边，而我是一个阅读自己虚构故事太迟钝的人，没发现她潜伏在其中。
The rookie story goes on, but over time, at Luke's urging, it became more and more detached from baseball. The rookie entered a gothic phase as the little boy began to demand scary rookie stories, with a real witch-- not Ty Cobb dressed up like a witch, not the Chief dressed up like a witch, a real witch. Over time, inside the rookie's suitcase, the one his mama packed the day he left for New York, the rookie has come to find a complete dictionary of the animal languages, a saxophone, a design for the first car radio, compressed early rocket ship refueling pills, a map of Paris, a window defogger, a time machine, a map of a secret route to the South Pole, and reindeer medicine for Santa's team. The story belongs to Luke now.
新人的故事还在继续，但随着时间的推移，在卢克的催促下，它变得越来越脱离棒球了。新人进入了一个哥特式阶段，因为小男孩开始要求讲恐怖的新人故事，带着一个真正的女巫——不是穿得像女巫的泰·柯布，不是穿得像女巫的迈尔斯，是一个真正的女巫。随着时间的推移，在那个新人离开纽约那天妈妈给他收拾的手提箱里，新人已经找到了完整的动物语言词典、萨克斯风、第一台车载收音机设计图、压缩的早期火箭推进燃料药丸、巴黎地图、窗户除雾器、时间机器、通往南极的秘密路线图，以及圣诞老人团队的驯鹿药水。这个故事现在属于卢克了。
I don't think about the rookie as much as I used to, but when the bombs began to fall in Serbia I began thinking about that other Serbian conflagration in 1914, and everything it had led to. And I realized with a start that by making the rookie three years old in 1908, I was leaving him unprotected to the century's horrors. Then I did a quick calculation and realized that he would have been far too young for the first World War and just too old for the second. The rookie was lucky that way, I think.
我不像以前那样经常想到那个新人了，但当炸弹开始在塞尔维亚投下时，我开始想到1914年那场塞尔维亚大火，以及它所导致的一切。我猛然意识到，把新人设定为1908年的三岁，我让他毫无保护地面对了那个世纪的恐怖。然后我快速计算了一下，意识到对于第一次世界大战来说他太小了，对于第二次世界大战来说又太老了。我想，新人在这方面很幸运。
Luke and I tried playing a little catch this spring in the Luxembourg Gardens, but gave up after about five minutes. For a present around that time, he asked us to make him his own [SPEAKING FRENCH] marked with a [SPEAKING FRENCH] a press pass from the government like the one I have, so that he could pretend to cut through red tape. We made him an impressive-looking fake French government document, with a black and white photo and lots of cryptic official-looking stamps.
今年春天，卢克和我试着在卢森堡公园玩了一会儿接球，但五分钟后就放弃了。那段时间他过生日，他要求我们给他做一个[法语]，上面印着[法语]，这是像我那样的政府记者证，这样他就可以假装砍断红头文件。我们为他做了一个看起来很有说服力的伪造法国政府文件，上面有黑白照片和许多神秘的官方印章。
At bedtime now, before the rookie story starts, he likes to act out a French bureaucratic drama. I play a functionary guarding an entrance to something or other, who scowls at him until he haughtily flashes his carte. And then I let him pass with many apologetic, "Ah, Monsieur. I did not recognize--" grimaces and shrugs, while his mother acts out the role of irate bystander, fuming in line as the privileged functionary serenely passes by. I suppose it's about time we took him home.
现在在睡前，在新人故事开始之前，他喜欢演一出法国官僚戏。我扮演一个守卫入口的职员，对他怒目而视，直到他傲慢地亮出他的卡。然后我以许多道歉的“啊，先生。我没认出——”这样的表情和耸肩让他通过，而他的母亲扮演愤怒的旁观者，在他作为特权官僚平静走过时，在队伍里愤愤不平。我想是时候带他回家了。
Adam Gopnik's story "The Rookie" can be found in his book Paris to the Moon. He's a writer for The New Yorker magazine.
亚当·戈普尼克的故事《那个新人》可以在他的书《巴黎到月亮》（Paris to the Moon）中找到。他是《纽约客》杂志的撰稿人。
[MUSIC - "AT HOME HE'S A TOURIST" BY GANG OF FOUR]
[音乐 - Gang of Four的《在家里他是游客》]
Act Three, It's Julie Andrews's World, Sylvia Just Lives in It. A few years ago, on her 18th birthday, Sylvia Lemus came onto our program and talked about her life. Her parents are immigrants, very traditional, from Mexico, and they wanted her to get married right away, have babies. But Sylvia grew up in this country and she thought like an American girl. She wanted to go to college, get an interesting job, all that before she started a family. Here's what she said at the time.
第三幕，《这是朱莉·安德鲁斯的世界，西尔维娅只是生活在其中》。几年前，在西尔维娅·莱姆斯（Sylvia Lemus）18岁生日时，她来到我们的节目，谈论了她的生活。她的父母是移民，非常传统，来自墨西哥，他们希望她立刻结婚、生孩子。但西尔维娅在这个国家长大，她的想法像个美国女孩。她想上大学，找一份有趣的工作，在组建家庭之前做所有这些事。以下是她当时说的话。
My mom has lived in a box all her life. And I sometimes-- once in a while I'll escape from the box. And sometimes I'll just try to climb out, and she's pushing me in. Or I'm trying to poke a hole in the box and she tapes it right back up.
我妈妈这辈子都活在一个盒子里。我有时——偶尔我会从盒子里逃出来。有时我试着爬出来，她却把我往里推。或者我试着在盒子上戳个洞，她马上就把它粘回去。
Sometimes we get into fights, and I tell my mom, I'm not like my cousins. I'm not. My cousins are 19, 18, and they're already pregnant or married. I'm like, is that what you want me to do with my life?
有时我们会吵架，我告诉妈妈，我不像我的表亲们。我不像。我的表亲19岁、18岁就已经怀孕或结婚了。我心想，这就是你们想让我过的一生吗？
At that time, Sylvia had a perfectly clear picture of what she wanted her life to be. She'd work in a big open office, with lots of computers and gadgets, doing computer animation on films like Jurassic Park and Men in Black .
那时候，西尔维娅对自己想要的生活有非常清晰的蓝图。她想在一个宽敞明亮的办公室工作，有许多电脑和小玩意，在《侏罗纪公园》和《黑衣人》这样的电影里做电脑动画。
You know, sitting in front of the computer and doing all these things on the computer, and animating and getting really frustrated because it takes me like six months to do a five-second little scene. And I'd have an eyebrow ring or something on, have my hair whatever color I want.
你知道，坐在电脑前做这些事，做动画，然后感到非常沮丧，因为做一个五秒钟的小片段花了我六个月。我还会打个眉环之类的，把头发染成我想要的任何颜色。
After that interview, Sylvia started hanging around our office, became an intern on our show. And then she went away to college, to a school that she chose because they teach computer animation, the Rochester Institute of Technology in New York. She took one of our tape recorders with her and recorded now and then, tape diaries about her experience in college and moments with her friends. We've pulled some clips from the tape, and I talked to her about it all.
那次采访后，西尔维娅开始常来我们办公室，成了我们节目的实习生。然后她去上大学了，她选择这所学校是因为他们教电脑动画，就是纽约的罗切斯特理工学院（RIT）。她带了我们的一台录音机去，时不时地录制一些关于她大学经历和与朋友们在一起时刻的录音日记。我们从中选出了一些片段，并和她谈了谈。
So Shari invited us to a crew party, and there was this guy named Zack who showed us to the boat house. And, oh my god, to a city girl, this was amazing. The boat house had no lighting whatsoever, and above that you see stars. Not city stars, like one or two-- stars. A lot of stars. And I looked up and I was amazed, and the first thing I said-- "Oh, my god, look, there's a box." Apparently it's the Big Dipper or the Little Dipper. I'm not quite sure exactly what it was. And they were kind of laughing at me, because I'm like, "Oh, my god, there's a box. A box was shaped there."
所以莎莉邀请我们参加船员派对，有个叫扎克的家伙带我们去了船屋。天哪，对于一个城市女孩来说，这太神奇了。船屋里一点灯光都没有，而在那之上你看到了星星。不是城市里的星星，那什么一两颗——星星。很多星星。我抬头看，惊呆了，第一句话就是：“天哪，看，那有个盒子。”显然那是北斗七星或小熊座。我不太确定到底是什么。他们都在笑我，因为我当时说：“天哪，那有个盒子。那儿有个盒子形状的东西。”
Can I also get a strawberry smoothie with whipped cream? Thank you.
我还能来个加奶油的草莓奶昔吗？谢谢。
Biscotti.
意式脆饼（Biscotti）。
What exactly is it? You know how uncultured I am.
那到底是什么？你知道我多没文化。
I know you from Chicago, so--
我是从芝加哥认识你的，所以——
I'm just telling you that not everything here is universal.
我只是告诉你，这里不是所有东西都是通用的。
Biscotti is just a crunchy biscuit-type thing. Those have chocolate. Some of them have almonds. Some of them are chocolate all together. Don't you remember I brought them in with my Fruit Roll-Ups?
Biscotti就是一种脆饼干。那些加了巧克力。有些加了杏仁。有些全是巧克力做的。你不记得我带着它和果丹皮一起带过来吗？
Yeah, but I didn't taste any. [INTERPOSING VOICES] I didn't taste them.
记得，但我没尝过。[交错的声音] 我没尝过。
I know, but you asked me what it is like if you didn't know.
我知道，但你问我那是什么，就好像你不知道一样。
Sylvia, do you feel like your friends at school understand you?
西尔维娅，你觉得学校里的朋友理解你吗？
A lot of times, no. I don't think they do. Like, I've never seen The Sound of Music. Is that what it's called? Or something and a chocolate factory? I've never seen any of that stuff.
很多时候，不。我不觉得他们理解。比如，我从没看过《音乐之声》。是叫这个名字吗？或者是别的什么巧克力工厂？我从来没看过那些东西。
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory.
《威利·旺卡与巧克力工厂》。
Yeah. I've never seen any of that stuff. And I'm just used to going to an all-ghetto school where everybody speaks Spanglish and a lot of music is blaring outside our window 24/7. And they're like, "Oh, my gosh, she's so different. She's not like what we grew up with."
对。我从来没看过那些。我习惯去那种到处是贫民区的学校，每个人都说西裔英语（Spanglish），我们窗外24小时全天候播放着大声的音乐。他们会说：“天哪，她太不一样了。她不像我们成长环境里的人。”
Where's your sister?
你妹妹在哪？
My sister's that little one with the [UNINTELLIGIBLE] New Kids on the Block shirt. That's when she was six. Now she's 13.
我妹妹就是那个穿“街头顽童”（New Kids on the Block）衬衫的小家伙。那是她六岁的时候。现在她13岁了。
No, [? I mean ?] real pictures of her.
不，[？我的意思是？] 她的真实照片。
Yeah, I do have real pictures of her.
是的，我有她的真实照片。
Oh, I want to see her.
哦，我想看她。
Why? That's her right there. And that's my brother and that's me. These are my grandparents in Mexico.
为什么？那就是她。这是我弟弟，这是我。这是我墨西哥的祖父母。
Oh, wow. They look so original. That looks so cool.
哇。他们看起来太原创了。看起来太酷了。
They look original? What do you mean, original?
他们看起来原创？你什么意思，原创？
I don't know. They look cool. I like their outfits and everything, very traditional.
我不知道。他们看起来很酷。我喜欢他们的服装之类的，非常传统。
Yeah, that's very Mexican outfits.
是啊，那是非常墨西哥的服装。
Yeah, that's what I'm looking for. Traditional, not original.
没错，这就是我在找的词。传统，不是原创。
Have there been classes that you've really loved?
有没有你真正喜欢的课程？
I liked my visual anthropology class, because for the first time in a really long time, I felt like I can do what everybody else did, study the night before and get the exact same grade. That was the only class where I felt like I didn't have to try as hard and get less grades. I tried exactly the same as they did and I got the exact same grade. I loved that class.
我喜欢我的视觉人类学课，因为这是很长一段时间以来，我第一次觉得我可以做别人做的事情，前一天晚上学习，拿到完全一样的分数。那是唯一一门让我觉得不必那么努力也能拿到不错分数的课。我付出了和他们一样的努力，拿到了完全一样的分数。我爱死那门课了。
You're saying you loved it because it was kind of easy.
你是说你喜欢它是因为它有点简单。
Yeah. And I loved it because we had to do an ethnographic film, and we decided to shoot drag queens. And it was the best thing ever. I went out all the time. Like the last two weeks, we went out all the time to shoot at the Miss Gay Rochester pageant. And we shot them at their clubs and them dressing, and I came home drunk all the time. It was the funnest thing ever. I think that's why I like the class so much, because I always got drunk at the end.
是的。我喜欢它是为了拍一部民族志电影，我们决定拍变装皇后。那是史上最棒的事情。我一直都在外面。比如最后两周，我们一直在外面拍“罗切斯特同志小姐”选美比赛。我们拍她们在俱乐部和梳妆打扮，我每次回家都喝得醉醺醺的。这是史上最有趣的事。我想这就是我那么喜欢那门课的原因，因为我最后总是会喝醉。
How hard were your actual classes for you?
你的专业课对你来说有多难？
They were hard. It just seemed like no matter how hard I tried, I was never able to compete with them. I think a lot of it has to do with-- it's obvious that they went to better schools than I did. And I went to-- I don't even bother telling them that I WOMAN: was one of the top kids in my class. What are they going to say? "You were? What the hell happened?"
很难。似乎无论我多努力，我永远无法和他们竞争。我认为这很大程度上是因为——很明显，他们上的学校比我好。而我去的是——我甚至懒得告诉他们我曾经是班上前几名的学生。他们会说什么？“你是吗？到底发生了什么？”
Here's a recording that you made right after you got back to school after going home to Chicago for Christmas break.
这是你圣诞假期回芝加哥后，回到学校录制的录音。
January 2, I went to my cousin's baby shower. Everybody was there when we got there, so I had to go around the whole entire place, you know, greeting everybody. The handshake, the kiss, the hug, the kiss, the handshake. Blah blah blah. It took me 15 minutes to greet everybody, because there was at least 50 or 60 women. So I sat down with all my aunts and cousins, and everybody at that table was married with kids. I was only one without a child or a husband. And so we just like-- it was kind of bad. I mean I just noticed, nobody was in college, nobody was going for a profession. I don't know what to do with them. I really don't.
1月2日，我去参加了我表亲的迎婴派对。我们到的时候每个人都在，所以我不得不绕着整个地方，你知道，问候每个人。握手，亲吻，拥抱，亲吻，握手。叽里呱啦。花了我15分钟才问候完，因为至少有50或60个女人。我坐在我的姨妈和表亲们中间，那桌上的每个人都结婚了，有了孩子。我是唯一一个没有孩子或丈夫的人。所以我们只是——这感觉有点糟糕。我的意思是，我注意到，没有人上大学，没有人追求职业。我不知道该怎么办。我真的不知道。
And I hate that. At Rochester I spend most of my time wanting to be Mexican and wanting to hang out with Hispanic people, and then when I go to my family, I can't. It's like I spend half of my time defending where I'm from and where I was raised and why I was raised where I was. And then I'm stuck here and I'm basically defending something I don't even feel I'm part of.
我讨厌这样。在罗切斯特，我大部分时间都想成为墨西哥人，想和西裔待在一起，然后当我回到家人身边，我却做不到。就好像我有一半时间在为我来自哪里、我在哪里长大、为什么我在那里长大而辩护。然后我被困在这里，我基本上在为某种我甚至不觉得属于自己的东西辩护。
Hey, Sylvia, one of the things that happened during your first year when you were away at school is that at some point, you came back home and you went to the baptism of a baby, who was the baby of a cousin of yours.
嘿，西尔维娅，你在外地读书的第一年发生过一件事，就是有一次你回家去参加了一个婴儿的洗礼，那是你表亲的孩子。
Wait, hold on, I'm trying to remember which baptism.
等等，等等，我在努力想是哪次洗礼。
You have a cousin whose husband's in construction and she works and they have a three-room house.
你有位表亲，她丈夫干建筑的，她也工作，他们有个三居室的房子。
Oh yeah, Cristina. OK, so I go to her house. She's 19 and she has a house. I go to her house, and she lives in a very nice neighborhood not that far away from mine. And she works for a bank and she makes pretty good money and she only has a high-school degree. She got married two weeks shy of her 17th birthday. She had her kid when she was 19. And so she's having her daughter's baptism, and she has this beautiful house, this three-bedroom, attic and basement, house. And it's well-decorated.
哦对，克里斯蒂娜（Cristina）。好的，我去她家。她19岁，有自己的房子。我去她家，她住在一个离我不远、非常不错的社区。她在银行工作，挣不少钱，只有高中学历。她在17岁生日前两周结婚的。她在19岁生了孩子。她在给她女儿办洗礼，她有这栋漂亮的房子，三卧、有阁楼和地下室。而且装饰得很漂亮。
And I think-- I'm like, "Hello, this is exactly the things that they tell you not to do, because this is not going to happen. If you get married, you're not going to have a house because out of a high-school degree, you don't really make that much money." But I'm like, why are they able to buy a house?
我就想——心想：“你好，这正是他们告诉你不要做的事情，因为这不可能发生。如果你结婚了，你不可能有房子，因为高中学历挣不了那么多钱。”但我心想，为什么他们能买得起房子？
And all I keep thinking is, oh, my god, I live in Rochester. I'm going to be living in an apartment the size of a closet with a roommate. It was like a backslap. I was already having problems with school, and then I come here and it's like, "Oh, look, we lied."
我一直在想，天哪，我住在罗切斯特。我以后要住在一个像壁橱那么大的公寓里，还得有室友。这就像被打了一巴掌。我在学校本来就有问题，然后来到这儿，就好像，“哦，看，我们撒谎了。”
Did you feel like all of us who have ever told you that it would be a good idea to go away to college and get a degree--
你觉得我们这些曾经告诉你去外地上大学拿学位是个好主意的人——
Yeah, they're liars.
是的，他们是骗子。
Really?
真的吗？
No, I'm just joking. But sometimes I'm like, I think they lied to me. I think they did. But I know the feelings I'm having right now are just because I'm having problems. But at this point I don't see the happiness I saw when I was in high school. Remember when I told you, I pictured to have this huge office with toys and computers and stuff like that?
不，我开玩笑的。但有时我会想，我觉得他们对我撒谎了。我觉得他们撒谎了。但我知道我现在有的这些感觉只是因为我遇到了困难。但在这一点上，我看不到我高中时看到的快乐了。记得我告诉过你吗，我曾梦想拥有一个巨大的办公室，里面有玩具和电脑之类的东西？
Yeah.
记得。
I don't see that anymore. Right now, it seems like it's a scam, that I was fooled into something, that I was naive enough to think that that dream could actually happen, you know?
我再也看不到了。现在，这看起来像个骗局，我被愚弄进了某种东西，我天真地以为那个梦想真的会实现，你知道吗？
Sylvia, do you think that if you quit the life that you're having right now and tried to move back to the neighborhood where you grew up, and meet somebody and have babies and have a house, do you think you could even do that?
西尔维娅，你觉得如果你放弃现在的生活，试着搬回你长大的街区，找个人结婚生子，买个房子，你觉得你能做到吗？
I'd be miserable.
我会很痛苦的。
You'd be miserable.
你会很痛苦。
No, I'd be miserable.
不，我会很痛苦。
Why?
为什么？
Because that's not the life I want. That's not the life I want, but this life isn't being very accepting to me.
因为那不是我想要的生活。那不是我想要的生活，但这种生活也不接受我。
So you're kind of stuck.
所以你有点被困住了。
Yeah. I am, aren't I? I am stuck.
是的。我是吧？我被困住了。
Well, time passed again, and two years after that interview was recorded, Sylvia graduated from the limbo that was RIT in 2003. And since then, she's been living in a different kind of limbo in Los Angeles, working various jobs, trying to break into film production. She still sees very similar pros and cons to the choices that she's made. Right now, she works  for a multimedia company in Hollywood.
嗯，时间又过去了，在那次采访录音两年后，西尔维娅于2003年从RIT那个“中间状态”毕业了。从那以后，她一直生活在洛杉矶另一种中间状态中，做着各种工作，试图打入电影制作圈。对于自己的选择，她仍然能看到非常相似的利弊。现在，她在好莱坞一家多媒体公司工作。
Well, our program was produced today by Blue Chevigny and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Jonathan Goldstein, and  Starlee Kine. Our senior producer, Julie Snyder. Production help from Annie Baxter and Todd Bachmann.
好吧，我们的节目今天由布鲁·谢维尼（Blue Chevigny）和我制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格、乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）和斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）参与。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。制作助理安妮·巴克斯特（Annie Baxter）和托德·巴克曼（Todd Bachmann）。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资金支持名单]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our programs for absolutely free, 24 hours a day. You know, you can download today's program at our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，您可以在那里全天24小时免费收听我们的节目。你知道，你可以在audible.com/thisamericanlife的档案中下载今天的节目。
WBEZ management oversight for our program by Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, every time he sees me in the hall, he taunts me. He taunts me this way.
WBEZ对我们节目的管理监督是托里·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，每次他在走廊见到我，他都会嘲笑我。他这样嘲笑我。
Hey, everybody, look at the crybaby. Hey, baby. Hey, crybaby.
嘿，大家看那个爱哭鬼。嘿，宝贝。嘿，爱哭鬼。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life .
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
Why don't you cry some more, crybaby?
你怎么不再多哭一会儿呢，爱哭鬼？
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。